just as a human being let me ask you
about this one particular anecdotal
evidence of the google engineer
who made a comment
or
believed that there's some aspect of a
language model
the lambda language model that exhibited
sentience
so you said you believe there might be a
responsibility to build systems that are
not essential and this experience of a
particular engineer i think i'd love to
get your general opinion on this kind of
thing but i think it will happen more
and more and more
which uh not when engineers but when
people out there that don't have an
engineering background start interacting
with increasingly intelligent systems
we anthropomorphize them they they start
to have
deep impactful
um interactions with us in a way that we
miss them yeah when they're gone
and we sure feel like they're
living entities self-aware entities and
maybe even we project sentience onto
them so what what's your thought about
this particular
uh system was is uh
have you ever met a language model
that's sentient
no no what do you make of the case of
when you kind of
feel
that there's some elements of sentience
to this system
yeah so this is you know an interesting
question and a uh obviously a very
fundamental one so first thing to say is
i think that
none of the systems we have today i
would say even have one iota of uh
semblance of consciousness or sentience
that's my personal feeling interacting
with them every day so i think it's way
premature to be discussing what that
engineer talked about i appreciate i
think at the moment it's more of a
projection of the way our own minds work
which is to see
uh uh uh sort of purpose and direction
in almost anything that we you know our
brains are trained to interpret uh uh
agency basically and things uh even an
inanimate thing sometimes and of course
with a a language system because
language is so fundamental to
intelligence that's going to be easy for
us to anthropomorphize that um i mean
back in the day even the first uh
you know the dumbest sort of template
chatbots ever eliza and and and and the
ilk of the original chatbots back in the
60s fooled some people under certain
circumstances right they pretended to be
a psychologist so just basically rabbit
back to you the same question you asked
it back to you um
and uh some people believe that so i
don't think we can this is why i think
the turing test is a little bit flawed
as a formal test because it depends on
the sophistication of the of the judge
um whether or not they they are uh
qualified to make that distinction so
i think we should uh talk to you know
the top philosophers about this people
like daniel dennett and uh david
chalmers and others who've obviously
thought deeply about consciousness of
course consciousness itself hasn't been
well there's no agreed definition if i
was to you know uh speculate about that
uh you know i kind of the definite the
working definition i like is it's the
way information feels when you know it
gets processed i think maybe max tegmark
came up with that i like that idea then
if it helps us get towards any more
operational thing but but it's it's it's
i think it's a nice way of viewing it um
i think we can obviously see from
neuroscience certain prerequisites that
are required like self-awareness i think
is necessary but not sufficient
component this idea of a self and other
and set of coherent preferences that
that are coherent over time you know
these things are maybe memory um these
things are probably needed for a
sentient or conscious being um but but
the reason that the difficult thing i
think for us when we get and i think
this is a really interesting
philosophical debate is when we get
closer to agi and and and you know
and and much more powerful systems than
we have today
how are we going to make this judgment
and one way which is the turing test is
sort of a behavioral judgment is is the
system exhibiting all the behaviors um
that a human sentient uh or a sentient
being would would exhibit um is it
answering the right questions is it
saying the right things is it
indistinguishable from a human um and so
on
but i think there's a second thing that
makes us as humans regard each other as
sentient right why do we why do we think
this and i debated this with daniel
dennett and i think there's a second
reason that's over often overlooked
which is that we're running on the same
substrate right so if we're exhibiting
the same behavior uh more or less as
humans and we're running on the same you
know carbon-based biological substrate
the squishy you know a few pounds of of
flesh in our skulls then the most
parsimonious i think explanation is that
you're feeling the same thing as i'm
feeling right but we will never have
that second part the substrate
equivalence with a machine
right so we will have to only judge
based on the behavior and i think the
substrate equivalent is a critical part
of why we make assumptions that we're
conscious and in fact even with with
animals high-level animals while we
think they might be because they're
exhibiting some of the behaviors we
would expect from a sentient animal and
we know they're made of the same things
biological neurons so we're going to
have to come up with
explanations
or models of the gap between substrate
differences between machines and humans
did to get anywhere beyond the
behavioral but to me sort of the
practical question is
very interesting and very important when
you have millions perhaps billions of
people believing that you have ascension
ai believing what that google engineer
believed
which i just see is an obvious
very near-term future thing
certainly on the path to agi
how does that change the world
what's the responsibility of the ai
system to help those millions of people
and also what's the ethical thing
because
you can you can make a lot of people
happy
by creating a meaningful deep experience
with a system
that's faking it before it makes it yeah
and i i don't
is are we the right or who is to say
what's the right thing to do
should ai always be tools like why why
are we constraining ais to always be
tools as opposed to
friends yeah i think well i mean these
are you know you know fantastic
questions and and also critical ones and
we've been thinking about this uh since
the start of deepmind and before that
because we planned for success and you
know how how you know you know however
remote that looked like back in 2010 and
we've always had sort of these ethical
considerations as fundamental at
deepmind um and my my current thinking
on the language models is and and large
models is they're not ready we don't
understand them well enough yet um and
you know in terms of analysis tools and
and guard rails what they can and can't
do and so on to deploy them at scale
because i think you know there are big
still ethical questions like should an
ai system always announce that it is an
ai system to begin with probably yes um
it what do you do about answering those
philosophical questions about the
feelings uh people may have about ai
systems perhaps incorrectly attributed
so i think there's a whole bunch of
research that needs to be done first um
to responsibly before you know you can
responsibly deploy these systems at
scale that would be at least be my
current position uh over time i'm very
confident we'll have those tools like
interpretability questions um
and uh analysis questions uh and then
with the ethical quandary you know i
think there
it's important to uh look beyond just
science that's why i think philosophy
social sciences even theology other
things like that come into it where um
what you know arts and humanities what
what does it mean to be human and the
spirit of being human and and to enhance
that and and the human condition right
and allow us to experience things we
could never experience before and
improve the the overall human condition
and humanity overall you know get
radical abundance solve many scientific
problems solve disease so this is the
era i think this is the amazing era i
think we're heading into if we do it
right um but we've got to be careful
we've already seen with things like
social media how dual use technologies
can be misused by firstly by
by bad you know p bad actors or naive
actors or crazy actors right so there's
that set of just that common or garden
you know misuse of existing dual use
technology uh and then of course there's
an additional uh uh thing that has to be
overcome with ai that eventually it may
have its own agency so it could be uh uh
uh good or bad in in of itself so i
think these questions have to be
approached very carefully um using the
scientific method i would say in terms
of hypothesis generation careful control
testing not live a b testing out in the
world because with powerful dual
technologies like ai um if something
goes wrong it may cause you know a lot
of harm before you can fix it it's not
like a you know an imaging app or game
app where you know that if if something
goes wrong it's relatively easy to fix
and and the harm's relatively small so i
think
it comes with you know the the the usual
uh cliche of like with a lot of power
comes a lot of responsibility and i
think that's the case here with things
like ai given the enormous opportunity
in front of us and i think we need a lot
of voices uh and as many inputs into
things like the design of the systems
and the values they should have and what
goals should they be put to
i think as wide a group of voices as
possible beyond just the technologists
is needed to input into that and to have
a say in that especially when it comes
to deployment of these systems which is
when the rubber really hits the road it
really affects the general person in the
street rather than fundamental research
and that's why i say
i think as a first step it would be
better if we have the choice to build
these systems as tools to give and i'm
not saying that it should never they
should never go beyond tools because of
course the potential is there um for it
to go way beyond just tools uh but um i
think that would be a good first step uh
in order for us to you know allow us to
carefully experiment understand what
these things can do
you